[Music]
hey what's up folks crazy she's over
there tearing [ __ ] up what are you
tearing [ __ ] up for
she's just started i know well we're all
in here so she just kind of she's gonna
act up she's throwing two books on the
ground oh yeah oh yeah she pulled some
books out she's not kidding if you're
doing the show pooks is our cat she's
not paying attention
just goes like this and starts pulling
books out of the shelves and then looks
at you and then leaves a little pile
yeah then she looks like you you're not
gonna she looks at you like you're not
gonna do anything no
not gonna do anything
she's blanking at me she's like yeah i'm
talking about she's like that's china
i'm talking about yeah we'll say hey
happy valentine's day everybody yeah tom
you should have worn a cupid outfit
no that's just natural it's just an
internal [ __ ] cupid aura
y'all had to you should have worn like a
diaper you all have to put those damn
effects on [ __ ] instagram
i like that just the way it is
[Music]
he's got that glow around it yeah
yeah just doesn't come across in [ __ ]
camera oh is that what it is
okay
the force doesn't go
digital lines yeah it has something to
do with the technological
holy [ __ ] yeah we uh we had our little
valentine's day lunch today
went to a new place because well we were
gonna go to momiji we're gonna go do
japanese and then i was just kind of
like oh wait like momiji isn't open on
mondays yeah and they were not open
today so i was like let's go get some
seafood so we went to a new place in
eustis i got it on video and it was
actually pretty good yeah i'll show it
to you the crazy gator yeah they have uh
say like fish and steaks and sandwiches
and they did have some gator they had a
gator po boy but i'm like that i don't
like alligators yeah i'm not a big fan
of it like it's not terrible but it's
not my favorite thing if there's other
things i just got shrimp and scallop and
some taters that's what i got
yeah we went there we went there kind of
early because we had other [ __ ] we had
to do
yeah see that's it's over on the uh on
the bay or river or whatever the [ __ ]
that is i don't know we've never been
over there before
never been over there
yeah we were like some of the first
people in there yeah they had just
opened it's just open
there were some people back there but
yeah but it was nice it was nice and
cold out so everybody was well it was
it's 50 it was 50 degrees
which is cold for florida so there were
people in jackets walking around out
there
yeah a new place where there's like
three or four seafood restaurants right
along that road but we've never been up
there before
so uh yeah that was pretty good tom also
got me like a big old
box of uh truffles yeah so i'm gonna put
some weight on it
like i need anything like i need
here go well i had to hide the box
because because it's like it's it's
squishy on no because it's squishy on
the top and pookie's like uh i can sit
and i'm like let's let's not sit on that
because it's squishy like a cushion
uh but yeah so we thought because it was
valentine's day and because
shutter just added this movie not too
long ago and we did my bloody valentine
last year
so i was like well let's do valentine
from 2001 slasher movie you know what's
weird though i watched when we watched
it i could have sworn that i had seen it
before
but when i was watching it again i'm
like you know what i don't think i did
see this or if i did see it i didn't
remember anything about it you know yeah
i'm not a massive fan of slashers from
this era
and the strange thing about this is
because i kind of feel like they were
you know you had slashers they kind of
had their heyday like in the 80s
and then wes craven made scream in 1996
which sort of revitalized the genre but
a lot of the ones that came in the wake
of scream were kind of more self-aware
this one
not so much this one is actually kind of
more
like an 80s slasher
you know it almost kind of reminded me
like like a prom night or something like
that
but i'm not sure if that's a good thing
or a bad thing you know what i'm saying
yeah i really didn't get anything out of
this movie it's very like it's not bad
but yeah it's very
meh
it's just a movie of its time and movies
from this time were just like what just
very generic yeah it's just it's
basically like a whole bunch of like
pretty people who
and seriously it was like three blonde
chicks and i three blonde chicks four
blonde chicks i don't know and one dark
and and denise richards
but the other one standing out though
she was always cute yeah but like the
other ones were just kind of like wait
is this that one or that one
[Laughter]
you know i mean they just because they
kind of looked they had a similar kind
of look to them they did back then
everybody kind of did i know but you
know and especially like in these kind
of movies
um i will say this is not actually a bad
slasher for the time but like you said
it is it doesn't have like a super huge
amount of personality to it
but
there are some things i liked about it i
did like uh the mask that the killer had
like the cute that weird like cupid mask
i did like that that was distinctive
um i liked some of the kills
i liked some of the funny [ __ ] that they
put in it because the weird thing about
this is that it is a slasher movie but
it also has kind of like a mystery
element to it and there's a bunch of red
herrings because like pretty much every
man in this is a dirt bag
even the cop and and so i mean they set
it up that way for a reason so ever so
anybody could be the killer
um you know so i thought that was like
kind of entertaining so i liked that
mystery aspect to it and i didn't really
guess
exactly what the end was gonna be you
know what i mean
i didn't dislike the movie i just don't
remember much of it because it made very
little impression it was just kind of a
generic movie you could really
it really kind of brought me back to the
to this era
when a lot of things were kind of samey
i didn't really feel uh connected to to
a lot of these movies from this time
no me neither and this is just kind of
coming and going and you're like yeah
another one and yeah okay here's another
one they just
at this time in my life when these
things were coming out they just weren't
making an impression on me they were
just they were kind of coming across
almost like like hallmark movies from
hallmark they were like except horror
and horror yeah they were kind of yeah i
know what you're saying the old 70s and
80s ones even some of the 90s ones
because they were imperfect and [ __ ]
crazy you remembered them
and they you kind of get pulled into
them sometimes these were almost
two vanilla yeah i think that was the
price and honestly i had forgotten to
like watching this i was like oh my god
this is the most 2001 movie i've ever
seen i think just because because
everyone was just so bland and pretty
and also that soundtrack marilyn manson
orgy lincoln park i was just like oh my
god
it was just like i was like it's funny
because when you lived through that era
like when you lived through 2001 and you
were just kind of like you remember that
music
but
it didn't i don't know it didn't really
stand out but now like watching it now i
was just like oh my god that's like such
a time capsule of an era even though you
didn't really like realize it at the
time because at the time like nothing
seemed all that distinctive like when
you're living through it you know what i
mean it's only like in hindsight that
you're looking back and again oh my god
that's so 2001 that it hurts in 2001
this this uh movie would have been just
like really mainstream
that's how i would have well yeah it
definitely is now it did um i think this
only cost 10 mil to make and it did make
uh
a couple times its money back i think it
made 36 000 like million or 40 million
something like that so uh but i don't
it's for i don't think they made any
sequels or anything
um danny rowling said this film's way
better than the uh i know what you did
last summer films i will agree with that
yeah um
that kind of had well that's weird
because that was based on a novel too i
think so was this
uh this was based on a novel by tom
savage although i which i haven't read
but i heard that this was just very
loosely based on it and
i mean it was kind of floating around
for a long time before they actually got
it made which you know like most movies
about this is this actually had like
some pretty big stars in it like i said
denise richards was in it who i feel
like it was the law she had to be in
everything you know in 2001 late 90s
late 90s 2001 she was then she was in
all mid 90s too you know she was yeah
that's true [ __ ] starship troopers
yeah i remember her from wild things she
was in a [ __ ] ton of movies um this had
uh david uh what how do you pronounce
his last name brianna's or whatever from
angel you know yeah yeah that guy was in
there uh yeah that guy what you know
what's weird is i always confuse him
with uh that shafer guy that was in that
that was in uh
[ __ ] man what was that clyde barker
movie about midian
uh [ __ ] you know what i'm talking about
all that shit's a blur yeah because
is it me or do they like look the same
because i made i think i made when uh
david breanna's came up in this movie i
think i made a cr a joke about going
back to midian or something i'm like oh
wait that's not that shaffer did that
was in that i'm like oh [ __ ] that's not
funny anymore it will and um also
katherine heigl kegel heigl was in this
and i think
i i think the first time i saw her i
know she was on like a tv show around
this time but i didn't really watch any
tv i think the first time i'd seen her
was in knocked up with seth rogen and i
think that was
2006.
so she's pretty young in this in spoiler
alert she gets killed like pretty early
which honestly that was one thing that i
kind of liked is that
you think that she's going to be the
main character because she's like this
med student they kind of spend like a
lot of time with her and she's like oh i
have this final tomorrow and she's at
the morgue and everything like at the
opening in night breed night breed thank
you i don't know why i for some reason
that the name of that movie always
escapes me yeah yeah perez oscar perez
man yeah i agree man the scream
franchise was also vanilla as [ __ ] i
didn't like the screen i liked the first
one the other ones were okay but i
didn't really bother with them after i
just yeah i just
i wasn't into that [ __ ] when it when it
was appearing in this era i was more
into [ __ ] kind of like
gingersnaps i would like that kind of
stuff
yeah ginger snaps came out in 2000 so
like a year before yeah yeah it would
have been more but there was more movies
that were like that more more goth
more golf more underground stuff that
people and that was canadian that was
canadian yeah and uh stuff that really
didn't really uh that the mainstream
really
they wouldn't understand it
it's usually this [ __ ] would undersell
but you know
goss of the time understood it yeah yeah
i mean this one my stream is more like
scream in this
yeah yeah this one like i said there's
nothing necessarily wrong with this one
i did like i liked some of it you know
you know what was my favorite scene well
honestly one of my favorite scenes was i
like the scene where denise richards get
gets killed like in the hot tub where he
puts the the the cover over it then he's
like drilling through it like under her
shoulder and stuff i lied dug that and
then like she gets electrocuted so i did
like the kills in this but honestly my
favorite scene in this
was like not even a kill it was when
that dude
uh
picked up like was uh flirting with
denise richards at the party and he says
let's go upstairs i have a surprise for
you and i'm thinking in my head it's
your penis isn't it and then so like
they get up there and indeed it is his
penis and it's funny like the scene
because it's like he just drops his
pants like ta-da and she's like looking
at it and i'm like what does it have two
prongs or tentacles or what's the
surprise i've seen those so
and then
she and then she plays along with the
[ __ ] and then she ties him to the bed
and puts a [ __ ] because he asks her
to wax it yeah and i'm like you probably
don't want to use that terminology
because of course there's candles all
over the thing so she like drips hot wax
all over his dick so i thought that was
hilarious but i'm missing funny [ __ ]
because kevin hagel's a [ __ ] just like
brie larson the chicks that they're
chicks that think that they're better
than they are yeah i just brie larson
brie larson and her [ __ ] claws she
got [ __ ] claws for feet [ __ ]
she's wearing some [ __ ] open-toed
shoes and people were pointing out look
at her [ __ ] feet and they don't know
what it is that they're seeing
if you take a pretty a woman who's kind
of slender to begin with and you put her
on winstrol she'll lose a lot of [ __ ]
weight in her fingers and her [ __ ]
feet her toes
you because you start losing with the
weight in those
lower extremities
and they'll get hands that are kind of
[ __ ] bony looking and they'll get
feet that look like [ __ ] claws that's
the first thing that happens if you're
[ __ ] real thin and you're on winstrol
those they all take
performance drugs all of them
those uh starlit girls that are all
being hot and [ __ ]
if you think those girls are natural
you're [ __ ] crazy if you think all
those dudes that are buffed out you know
what i mean that in in their superhero
costumes you think those dudes are
natural you're a child those dudes are
on all kinds of [ __ ]
under doctor's supervision
but no they're on all kinds of stuff
that's that's just a side effect it's
funny they were talking about her feet
and i'm looking and i go oh yeah when
straw feet
yeah
mango says it's time hallmarks spanned
out into seasonal horror movies yeah
when are they going to do that i mean i
kind of want to see that once all once
wants to i i kind of feel like they they
i think do they do halloween ones i kind
of feel like i don't watch them but i've
seen
you know christmas ones and thanksgiving
ones and [ __ ] like that i don't know if
they do halloween ones but i'm sure
they're kind of like happy
clappy kind of like you know goosebumps
but not as scary
hallmark is trying hallmark channel is
making a living off the very end of the
baby boomers so you're talking 70s and
80s a lot of octogenarians and they're
not being replaced evidently their
numbers are going down
uh so
as their clientele ages out they're not
being replaced at a quick enough rate so
it would
behoove it if television would survive
which it won't okay but if hallmark
wants to survive as some kind of a
[ __ ] streaming service or a studio
they're gonna have to [ __ ] do [ __ ]
like that make horror movies
because it's low investment high return
which is really what a lot of channels
are trying to do trying to do with [ __ ]
like a haunting episode and [ __ ]
animal adventures haunted on the road
[ __ ] season seven they're making
horror movies is what they're doing
it's cheap and they get a hybrid get it
to get
an easy return but matt yeah imagine
that [ __ ]
get hallmark making horror movies they
would just change their name they would
have they because that brand i don't
think would
do well they should call it hell mark
they would call it something else like
hal mark and that would that would
actually be a brilliant
name hal mark
yeah i just thought after that off the
top of my [ __ ] head well you're not
sound steak you sound thank you
that's what advertising is all about
that's right i know i work in it
it's a good one and then you could yeah
and then at the end you'd have like a
little like a little devil tail the
pitchfork janet tell you i come up with
good [ __ ] book titles too i think i'm
a good book type
jenny did you find denise richards hot
and wild things yeah i mean she's just
hot in general um
you know what's weird about this movie
though i kind of feel like it needed
more nudity yeah um there was a lot of
because there wasn't really any nudity
was there there was a lot of like
scantily clad
ladies
uh
but not really any nudity that i
remember no boobies 2000's nudity wasn't
[ __ ] what wasn't real um illicit
anyway it didn't have that skankiness to
it the 70s and 80s knew that you have
that's quite the same
it's like you can't see the tan lines or
like a little bit of unshaven bush right
they weren't quite well
the girls didn't look [ __ ] enough they
looked homogenized in the 2000s
yeah that's true they kind of all looked
like they came out of the same factory
yeah they all kind of looked like they
just looked like they were all [ __ ]
came out of the same underwear catalog
yeah pretty much yeah they all went to
the same plastic surgeons i guess yeah
uh slasher friend says if you guys watch
that series buffy i saw it uh here and
there but i haven't seen a lot of it uh
there was an episode where this guy yeah
david boranes tries to ruin prom night
by using prom horror movies
uh to control these devil dogs oh that
sounds good okay but yeah so i
um yeah so this movie like i said the
plot of this movie actually kind of
reminds me of prom night except
valentine's day
and
because there's a it's a revenge thing i
can't you know what i did like the
mystery aspect of it there's not really
any secret necessarily about who the
killer is because at the very beginning
they do kind of like a prologue when all
these people were back in junior high i
want to say and it was like a
valentine's day dance and there's this
super nerdy kid named jeremy melton and
he's asking all the girls to dance the
girls that are going to grow up to be
the characters in the movie
and
they're all to greater or less lesser
degrees being like an [ __ ] like ew no
you know what i mean like that kind of
[ __ ] and then he asked this one girl
who's like the fat girl even though
she's like not fat later and he's like
well will you dance with me and she says
yeah and then they go make out but then
like all these other dudes like kids
like come and see them and she's like
rape rape and i was just like thanks
[ __ ] okay whatever and uh so
so now you're led to believe that this
jeremy melton person is now grown up
because they don't know what happened to
him and he's the one doing it because
he's signing he sends them these
valentines and they're signed jm so
that's very much like my bloody
valentine and
you know there's a whole nosebleed thing
where it's like the killer has a
nosebleed like jeremy melton had a
nosebleed back in the old days and
there's a little bit of a twist at the
end but not really but one thing that i
did like about it was that even though
they don't really make a secret about
who the killer probably is
um
they do have it so that well
it's pim but you don't know what he
looks like because they're like he could
have had like plastic surgery or
something like that because he was just
like in a reform school and then like he
disappeared and so they don't know what
happened to so he could look like
anybody so you know it could be your
boyfriend it could be that guy another
thing i like too is that
although i will say the first there are
some good kills in this
um as i mentioned but the first
45 minutes or something there's so many
characters and all the blondes kind of
look alike
and
they're it kind of
in a way this is almost kind of like a
hallmark horror movie because it kind of
goes into their like relationship
problems like hey we're going to turbo
dating hey we're doing this and this
that and the other and we're having all
these relationship problems so it goes
into that but there is some kind of some
funny moments with that because
one of the girls which one i guess it's
the katherine heigl characters this is
like the very beginning she's on this
blind date with this dude named jason
and jason is this really creepy
like he's kind of like really uh
traditionally handsome like with the
chisel draw and everything but he's one
of those guys he's like well you know
it's just natural evolution that you
know
like a man like me who is very
successful that you would be attracted
to me except he doesn't he talks to him
about himself in the third person so
he's like so you would be attracted to
jason because blah blah blah like he
sounds like a psychopath and it's like
so that part is actually kind of funny i
kind of wish they had done more with
jason because
as i said they're kind of trying to set
up because like every dude in this is
like some kind of [ __ ] psychopath or
something or like a sexual predator and
they're setting it up so it's like you
don't know who the killer is like it
could be anybody because everybody just
seems like a piece of [ __ ]
but
i kind of wish that they had winnowed it
down a little bit i think they went a
little too far out there with that
because there's too many incidental
characters like jason
they should have made him more of a
character because he's like at the
beginning he's in that scene but then
like you only see him like very briefly
like later on and he was like such a
psycho that i think that would have been
better but then there was like this
other thing where one of the other girls
kate has this creepy ass neighbor who
keeps asking her for a date and then
when she's out like he goes through her
underwear drawer and [ __ ] like that and
then he gets killed with an iron later
on so it's kind of like they set up all
these guys as like can't as you know red
herrings but then also sort of like
cannon fodder as well and i kind of wish
that they had like winnowed down the
cast a little bit because i think there
was just too much
going on at the beginning
um until you get to kind of like the
climax which takes place at this big
valentine's day party where all the
characters are kind of there at the same
time that a bunch of them get killed but
it would have been good to kind of like
pare that down a little bit i feel like
just streamline it and some of the
characters that were more funny
they could have and i don't really think
they needed that many girls either
that looked the same i kind of wish
i don't know maybe that's more realistic
because like yeah those kind of chicks
like would all hang out together
realistically yeah speaking of along
those lines
says uh denise richards was hot but i
bet after spending five minutes whether
the conversation would begin to get dry
you might be surprised well okay if that
were to happen it's because look there's
a certain kind of person that tense that
seems to go far at hollywood
and character is a problem with those
people it's kind of like the more
sociopathic you are the
the further you'll go in hollywood
but
it's not so much whether or not they
look good or not or they're pretty
there's kind of a stereotype about
pretty woman
me and jenny knows all kinds of pretty
[ __ ] man they can and um
no they're great you know
um
she had some of them look better than
denise richards and they have good
personalities and [ __ ] good sense of
humor and
you know [ __ ] yeah i do feel like i
can't stereotype good looking people
some of them are [ __ ] awesome i mean
you can't you shouldn't really
stereotype anybody but i do kind of feel
like and maybe it's less now than it
used to be but i do kind of feel like
that there is a stereotype particularly
with women that really really attractive
women are
[ __ ] or they're dumb or something and
that's not absolutely not the case what
happens is that some dumb chick can go
further than she really should be going
if she's real good looking
and that kind of sticks out
or if some big some chick is a [ __ ]
psychopathic
gold digger
and she looks great she'll go far too
but you're ignoring all the ones that
look great like that that are [ __ ]
normal or fantastic they don't stick out
as much yeah when they're going far you
know
and it's just because they're not as
annoying yeah anybody who's annoying
you're going to you're going to notice
you're going to notice that you're going
to what the [ __ ] is wrong with the
squeaky wheel against the grass that's
what i used to say
talking about brie larson and her straw
feet you know they were picking on her
feet because she's [ __ ] a [ __ ] and
the reason why she's a [ __ ] is because
she's constantly jacked up on winstrol
you know you put a woman on [ __ ]
hormones and steroids and [ __ ] she'll
get aggressive and she says crazy [ __ ]
and she says crazy [ __ ] in public so
there's backlash but that
people who don't know the [ __ ] deal
the reason why brie larson's a [ __ ] is
because she's [ __ ] constantly on
winstrol
he's just saying that's steroids
cheryl says uh watched picnic and
hanging rock last night wish it had a
better ending felt like the slow burn
didn't pay off uh we're gonna be talking
about that tomorrow
uh because i uh had not seen it for a
really long time so i was looking
forward to watching it we've already
watched it but we're gonna talk about it
uh tomorrow
and uh granthar also often speaks in the
third person red flag
yes it is uh oscar says boomers like to
paint the narrative that modern times
are vulgar but those movies from the 70s
and 80s were more raunchy much more much
worse yeah they were much worse they
were just [ __ ] openly i mean the
girls i mean particularly not so much
lately but i do kind of feel like
particularly movies horror movies um
in maybe the post scream era and before
the torture porn thing
um a lot of them were kind of like this
where they were very
you know they had murders and [ __ ] in
them and they were a little bit gory but
they were very sanitized and they were
very
pretty and they were very generic like
it was just a bunch of pretty people
getting sort of lightly stabbed kind of
thing
um you know everyone was pretty and rich
and
it was just a very generic like i said
no one was grubby or
it didn't really have a lot of grit to
it everything just had this kind of like
high glossy sheen
on it which doesn't
doesn't always work in horror i don't
know it depends on what you're doing
because i have seen some like that but
ones that are that have that sheen on
them
i think it works better and horror if
you're satirizing that more than like
making it a regular movie
uh slasher fred also points out and this
is another thing that i wanted to point
out so thank you for reminding me
i've noticed how the insults these mean
girls give the outcast foreshadows their
murders yeah i actually didn't realize
that until i thought about it later on
because at the
the scene where they're in junior high
at the dance and he goes up and asks
each girl to dance and they give him
various like brush offs like you know
ooh i'd rather i think one of them says
i'd rather drown or i'd rather something
like that um and then that was that
turned out to be denise richards and she
drowns in the [ __ ] uh hot tub or
whatever so whatever they say
because i think the girl that just says
ew gross or something she's the one that
gets the chocolates that have all the
maggots in it because there's that
um you know she gets chocolates with
maggots in it uh let's see do do do do
danny rowling says uh a bio story film
on killer's leonard lake and charles eng
would be cool to see have they not i
mean we did a show about it but he was
talking about like oh like a biopic on
them yeah i think somebody tried to do
one a uh
a [ __ ] like like a fan film versus a
real low budget version of the
thing is the problem with that one
is that they don't know all the details
they know they killed a bunch of people
but they're not exactly sure what they
did to them
you know they did so they'd have to like
use they'd you'd have to use your life
charles [ __ ] yang wrote drew pictures
that made you know when he was in prison
that may have had given shed some light
on what they did to him if it was true
it's [ __ ] horrible cooking some of
them alive and
giving them their [ __ ] baby bones
back and [ __ ] because they'd take the
[ __ ] babies from the women and then
tell them that they had the baby keep it
safe and then they'd [ __ ] come back
and give the bones to the bed it just
[ __ ] if they but
they don't know if they actually did
that or if they just fantasized about
that but they did kill those people the
kids and everything
made porn movies with the girls for a
while and then killed him
they had some damn videotapes of the
[ __ ]
bodies and sleeping bags and rigor
mortis in the [ __ ] wheelbarrow they
were burning them they found
thousands and thousands of burned up
bone fragments up there at their little
cabin
and they had some girlfriend who
evidently knew all about it
and didn't tell on them and uh
she went and stole some videotapes from
there before the [ __ ] police
had collected it from evidence
so she she stole some videos that they
had they were probably videos of her
because she was making porn with them
but it may have had
maybe her interacting with some of the
victims
so
it's weird man
there were two [ __ ]
marines that basically were getting
kicked out of [ __ ] service for being
[ __ ] bags
and uh so they're like let's go be the
best [ __ ] bags we can be yeah i guess
and they were stealing
full auto weapons from [ __ ] the train
uh and they were just
what was funny about ning is that
charles name wasn't even an american
citizen he was chinese
and i don't even even hear illegally
but it didn't matter they had him in
service somehow he was able to rig it
somehow where he could stay but he
wasn't from here if i remember he wasn't
a legal citizen i don't believe
all kinds of weird [ __ ] about that case
that was [ __ ] and i've seen some of
the video survives i've seen it they
weren't murdering anybody in the videos
but they were talking to those victims
and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it was almost like
cosplay or role-playing it didn't even
look real but it was real
yeah it's grace's [ __ ] yeah it's weird i
mean i think some of it's on [ __ ]
youtube well i mean you should be able
to find it yeah i've watched it on there
before i'm talking to some girl and
[ __ ] you know they're kind of cutting
their clothes off and saying you're
gonna have to go along with this if you
want to live type of deal and she's just
kind of going along with it and you can
tell she's like i cannot really believe
in what's happening but they got her
babe she's where's my baby just all your
babies asleep and it's sleeping like a
rock
[ __ ] crazy and they were doing [ __ ]
like
putting out
they would answer personal ads where
people were selling things like video
equipment and they'd go down there and
they'd [ __ ] abduct that whole family
and kill them and steal the [ __ ] and
keep the wife for a few weeks and then
kill her
up in some damn survivalist cabin
and [ __ ] leonard lake was trying to
get his whole breeding pod of [ __ ]
women so he could repopulate the planet
after [ __ ] armageddon would happen
and
but of course these dudes are [ __ ]
clowns you know
very fantasy prone
yeah yeah yeah very fantasy prone clown
but uh they had willpower though
they had enough willpower to build
that's not always that's not always a
good thing they had enough willpower to
build underground [ __ ] vaults and
[ __ ] steal [ __ ] and [ __ ]
uh steal people's money and get them to
sign things over to them they did weird
[ __ ] you know appropriating other
people's stuff how much better a place
would the world be if like psychos like
that were just lazy as [ __ ] yeah that
would be yeah they weren't lazy it's
weird they could just like lay around
and eat doritos and everyone else could
just live their lives happily unmolested
by these [ __ ] scumbags they could
make they had military backgrounds could
make machine guns and stuff
leonard lake had a [ __ ] charles had a
[ __ ] he built a full auto mac 10 and
he had it suppressed and everything
and uh i think he might have started off
with a semi-auto but it had been
converted to full auto which is not easy
because
you're going from [ __ ] a hammer fired
weapon to a direct bull back he went to
direct blowbacker
which is hard to do he had to
manufacture a bolt i don't know where he
got it maybe he bought a bolt
but um it was probably around during
that time but
so they weren't dummies
just [ __ ] lunatics and they were
clouds
you know in certain ways they just
weird mixture of attributes you know
very rare
to have a person who has skills and has
dedication and willpower
but then is fantasy prone and believes
in the [ __ ] that could never happen and
kind of like live their they were when
you see videos of them they're like
cosplayers
they're not like real people
yeah when you see the video you're like
like i would never take those dudes
seriously if i saw them
they just don't come across as serious
people they weren't they were clowns
whenever you meet anybody new you should
just assume they're a serial killer
until it's proven otherwise yeah
i'm just joking seriously they give off
they give off vibes grafters will
probably know what exactly what i'm
talking about there's a certain vibe
that a pathological liar gives off
because we grew up with a pathological
liar there's this weird artificial
almost ai feeling to them
and every one of them [ __ ] serial
killers if you listen to them has that
ai-ness to them
and i'll run across the person
where they talk that way and they're
kind of they kind of repel you you'll
meet and it's very rare that you find
them but when you do find one you go oh
that's one of them
it's just it doesn't necessarily mean
they're a serial killer it just means
that they're uh
they're a uh uh a pathological liar
i was just joking though yeah um yeah so
let me go back to this movie for a
second because i wanted to i had
forgotten to mention that this was
actually uh directed by jamie blanks who
was the same guy that did urban legend
now i feel like i don't think i saw
urban legend either although
i very well might have seen it and just
didn't remember because like i said i
kind of feel like i like slasher movies
okay it's not my favorite subgenre of
horror but if i'm gonna watch a slasher
i think i'd rather watch like kind of
more a sleazy like 70s or 80s ones i
kind of feel like slasher movies with
some exceptions
when you do them all slick like this
like this one or like urban legend or
something it doesn't work as well
um you really do like i said this one is
maybe a little bit elevated one because
the killer looked kind of cool and
distinctive and two because it had more
of a mystery element not like full-on
giallo or anything like that but it did
have more of a mystery element to it um
so i liked that about it but
i don't know it's not a bad movie but
it's just kind of like
you know if you've exhausted all the
other valentine's day horror movies and
there's really not that many like now
that i'm thinking about it like i said
my bloody valentine and the remake
and
i don't know
and picnic and hanging rock which is
not exactly a horror movie it's kind of
more like a creepy like a mystery type
thing uh we'll talk about that tomorrow
but so there's really not a lot uh but
shutter just added this
so you know if you're looking for
something to watch later and you have
shutter then you know you could do worse
it's not the worst slasher movie i've
i've seen
but
it's not super super memorable either it
does have some kind of like funny scenes
and some kind of cool [ __ ] in it but
it was just kind of like there you know
what i'm saying and now i will say that
it was better than
the prom night remake
which i can't remember what year that
came out but i remember not liking that
at all
because i remember that one just being
kind of is was this pg-13
i kind of fee i kind of feel like this
might have been pg-13 maybe not
it had that kind of vibe to it i'm not a
big fan
of i mean there are some exceptions
there were some good horror movies that
came out in the 90s
but i did like scream i did like some of
that kind of stuff but i do kind of feel
like after like the 90s and the early
2000s
i feel like horror just went too
slick like too corporate too
it just wasn't fun anymore if everything
seemed very samey
um you know until like i said you got
more kind of like the torture porn kind
of stuff which i didn't love but at
least it was going in a more
extreme
retro grind house kind of direction
which i'm kind of more into that
so
you know but but this is a decent
slasher from that time period and like i
said it's a slasher from 2001 that isn't
self-aware like a lot of the post-screen
slashers were it's a slasher that's very
much
like an 80s slasher like it's
very
earnest i guess it's not like
self-referential which i thought was
kind of interesting but other than that
i don't really know what else uh we
could talk about oh
remember you wanted to say when we were
driving back from the restaurant
um
we cause like i said that we went to the
restaurant we went to for lunch for
valentine's was
over on the river the bay or whatever
the [ __ ] and we'd never been over there
before so we were driving back this one
way and there's all these farms and
there's a farm there
that does
pick your own peaches peaches
strawberries and pick your own
strawberries and then there's another
organic farm that does organic honey and
blueberries it's like two different
farms and then right over here and they
might do beef yeah right next to us
right over here
i mean a couple hundred yards from here
i didn't know it was there they're about
200 head of cattle
just laying down out in there
yeah that's awesome
and
there's a couple different ways to do it
sometimes you can go there and um
buy
a baby
cow
and then pay for its feed for a couple
years and then when it's once it gets to
a certain size
they'll they'll uh slaughter and butcher
it for you and then it's yours
that that may be something i might look
at
you can buy a cow from them and pay for
the feed
and let it grow big then they handle it
and give it to you all in [ __ ]
cutlets
all in [ __ ]
once it's done
but then when we were driving back to
when we were talking about oh when you
know in the summer we should go and
check out you know
go pick some peaches and then suddenly
we smelled weed yeah i was like oh
there's another farm out there
somebody's growing some weed out yeah i
was like god damn it these farmers
[ __ ] grow weed like crazy well i mean
it might as well and they don't care
no no they don't care [ __ ] um that's
just
that's not a big as long as that shit's
kind of kept low that the feds don't
seem to be interested the state doesn't
seem to be interested i mean it's just
pot nobody cares anything they just
don't care they got bigger problems
um
but that was even in the suburbs what we
call it was the suburbs when we left it
wasn't when we moved there that last
place we were at
there was time we'd go out there and go
man that's [ __ ] weed strong well
there was a house
at the end of the trail that i used to
or the trail that i used to walk on
there was like a house yeah and i'm
pretty sure they were growing a bunch of
weed back in the woods because every now
and then you just smell a salad you
would really and well and i feel like
maybe they were trying out their new
batch and like see because it was really
really strong sometimes that's not the
smell of it burning though that's the
smell of the plants
i wonder why i couldn't smell it all the
time though i guess they do stuff it's
just every now and then yes there's
certain seasons where they the plants
give off that damn smell it might have
something to do with their reproductive
process
danny rowling says how surprised were
you by this ending's twist jenny did you
see it coming
um
i didn't i kind of figured
um you know this movie is like 20 years
old so uh david boreana is his character
who is the only guy in the movie who's
not a complete douchebag he's an
alcoholic
but that's pretty much his only problem
um but he's like the only nice guy so i
said well he's probably gonna be the
killer and he does seem like he's the
killer but then also he kind of set up
the
uh that character the former fat girl
she's not fat anymore but she was fat
when she was younger and um so he kind
of set her up as a killer so i don't
know if she actually killed some people
or if it was just like a setup and he
was actually the killer because he's the
one with the nosebleed so
but yeah i kind of did see it coming but
i didn't see it coming until like you
know the party toward the end
and um
mango says cherry falls was a pretty
good slasher from this period i've been
meaning to see that i don't think i've
ever seen it um i think shutter added
that one too not too long ago and i've
heard a lot of other people bring it up
and
uh
that had uh what's her name in it that
that girl that was in clueless that died
what was her name brittany britney
something
um i think she might have been in cherry
falls but yeah i've been meaning to like
uh get around to watching that so yeah
i'll get around to that uh one of these
days because i'm pretty sure that nasty
chick washed her hair in the toilet yeah
i was just kind of like
i think if it got to that like because
you know in the context of the scene she
was like taking a shower and her hair
was full of shampoo and then the water
got shut off
and so she was like i have she called
her you know landlord or whatever and
she's like hey the water's on uh you
know i have all this [ __ ] in my hair and
then i think i would have waited a
little bit longer for somebody to come
and turn the water on before i stuck my
head in the toilet even if it was clean
just saying you know what i'm saying i
kind of feel like there's
there there's other options that you
that you could have like utilized before
sticking your head in the toilet that
wouldn't have been the first thing that
i uh that i would jump to yeah brittany
murphy that's right yeah she was in
cherry falls but yeah you're not the
first person because i've heard a lot of
other people like say that that was
really good and kind of underrated so
yeah um i'll eventually get around to
seeing that one i'm pretty sure it's i
remember either seeing it on shutter or
seeing it like on to be on one of those
uh services all right so
anything else you would like to add nope
done
nope done done
done all right
well there's somebody on here so okay
well have a good uh rest of your
valentine's day everybody hope you're
having a good one
and uh we'll be back tomorrow talking
about another sort of valentine theme
movie which is picnic and hanging rock
the original peter weir version they
actually did a remake in 2018 which i
didn't even know about until yesterday
but i haven't seen that one so we're
going to be talking about that tomorrow
so we will see you guys tomorrow
afternoon
bye